[Music]
welcome everybody i am here with a very
special guest for this evening's stream
with dina do you know welcome welcome to
my stream thanks guys i'm so excited i
cannot um
words cannot describe the excitement um
so how make just sounds likewise
likewise dina proposed an idea which is
that since i like playing blitz and
focusing she offered her services in
answering all of the chat questions
exactly
while i play
that's right so we have a division of
labor yeah so chess player not just
player well
i mean you actually do the more
important part because you answered the
chess questions yeah chess blair and
streamer so that's the plan so daniel
will be concentrating on full chats very
special very um
really very serious chess we'll be
beating some some
300 scrolls some some lobsters and uh
i'll be uh taking care of you guys first
questioner
are you turkish interesting question
yeah i'm talk you're 100 turkish 100
and that's the best country in the world
how are you guys enjoying madrid how are
you enjoying madrid i absolutely love
madrid
yeah it's amazing working with
professionals professional team
professional
staff everything is so professional that
tim and i became professional
so i'm going to switch to the board i
guess
you'll use your own computer yeah i'll
take care of you guys on my own computer
i'm going to challenge some people let's
see who's online oh mvl is online shall
we mvl let's go but if he accepts i'm
gonna have to be super focused okay but
you you have to be super focused uh the
[ __ ] though he's playing okay i'm
playing mbl let's go
okay
okay compared to veer okay now he plays
kara khan but yornikesko
was
playing yeah i'm obviously going to lose
some rating but it's fine
it's okay we'll concentrate you
concentrate okay
if dina gives daniel massage on stream i
will give 50 subs if the subs is not
enough
if this stops is nothing
let's say um
500
500
oh okay
which way that's exactly the words
[Music]
no we're not playing probably we're
playing listen i'm going to speak slower
because i want you going to hear me
it's slower and slower
it's
quieter
quieter
it's my microphone
microphone
let's go here
you should
structure
very good structure usually here you
place some positional chests some strong
positional chests you bring pieces your
brain rigs
yeah
yeah we'll see we'll see when when you
lose another 100 writing
okay
i'll come back i'll get it back
[Music]
but danny doesn't care because he has a
bishop coming to f4
that's very beautiful
it's very beautiful indeed
tap on the mic please
sure easy
easy easy
[Music]
[Music]
don't watch don't look
don't look
uh why is daniel nothing the candidates
well it's 2024 daniel's gonna be in the
candidates 2024. it's coming guys
it is coming
does knight g4 work
no probably not
ah
there's a paul na
probably take it
down to 2024
are you gonna vote for danya
kennedy's 24
97 attacking the rook on d8
25.
she probably
oh my god that's a crazy idea
[Music]
danny would never date anyone under 23
000.
that's true
do i miss the world champ of our hearts
already
it's so sweet oh this guy
wow
i think we understood it
wow
wow
beautiful
the bishop g5 then his rookie five guys
attacking the queen on e3 and the bishop
on g5 and daniel would lose a piece
that was a beautiful one
it was really beautiful
knight d4
i need two
is there some compensation
not enough phones not enough phones
okay it's not fantastic over here look
d192
is not into an idea
is that into an idea
maybe
92 and then they put 25 there is no g2
check
king h2 protecting the queen a very
important move
in the mount look a bit strange
how many languages do you speak only
only 20 no 99
yeah
well he's not that fast maybe he'll make
it
he's too fast
he's not trying to tilt danya that's not
true that's not true i'm trying
uh i'm trying to be on tilt and i'm
trying to untilt
[Music]
right
let's go
another game mvl
and girl is also going to be in the
candidates 94
he's also going to be
there
imagine having
churn
imagine
i already imagined
is i'm real trying to impress dina or
danya
that's a good question i think i'm
will's trying to impress dina because he
he he already impressed danya with his
uh
i'm playing badly is it because of um
i mean it's like everyone's on a mission
against the game oh yeah sure
sure
including us
and we all ship it
i love mvl's shark photo he can smell
the blood in the water
okay i see my razor is not working now
so i'm gonna time out this guy
thank you daniel for lending me your
ferrari the other day
you're welcome
you're very much welcome
stop distracting you i'm not described
i'm not distracting him danny is
concentrated
you're a big fan from everybody
you're very welcome
uh
what
thanks for saving my grammar from drove
me what does that mean
[Music]
dan i still remember you rescued us with
your helicopter thank you
what the hell
what is all this
[Music]
unfortunately i think dean is used to
weird comments yeah that's why she's so
funny
ah
nice
drawing astonishing
beautiful okay
um
[Music]
i like your pawn structure
my font structure yeah i like your
construction bad shape though your your
king is is suffering that's true but oh
mailhouse thank you so much for 50. oh
my god 50
subs thank you so much
thank you very
much much appreciated
appreciate it he has a past phone that
is a little bit that's true but i'm
gonna play windy six oh you're good but
then he plays h5 i mean he has attacks
against everything oh
[Music]
madrid
oh no and no one has still banned him i
took care of him
mr
mr
bj you're you're not doing your job
let's see for
attacking oh rook is coming i like your
position no yes
this phone is protecting the king
okay if you if you wish so much
c4 candidates must come through madrid
miss amigos chills
um
gtr
what is gtr
sorry
uh
have you ever fired a second what would
you ask
yeah me and nep we know we have our
moments
that my friends is a chess legacy i like
opposition
this one
you're not gonna repeat are you you're
gonna play for a win civilization here i
don't remember what this it says after
civilization here
you're gonna pick for a win i'm gonna
fly him you're gonna flag him let's go
not yet though don't celebrate yet dude
not yet not yet no i'm not celebrating
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm you're cheering me
on yeah
oh and see i already messed it up it's
okay you got time
[ __ ]
good time
[Music]
get out
yay
let's go one one
versus world champion nvl
world champion
he is a world champion by the way
some say the queen was given her powers
to honor queen isabella yeah
how many times i heard that
i'm so tired definitely less than me
because you are taking care of pizza at
challenge chat oh yeah because you were
already here yeah and i was hearing for
the whole week
dan girl
guys did you give me a follow just out
of curiosity because i'm streaming right
now as well it's actually a crime not to
give you know
a crime it's a crime
uh somehow well it's easier than viewed
and realized yeah easily nice it's just
a show in the guy listen
oh we play chelsea
[Music]
h4 and you kick that knight out
he just kicked him out
just kick him out just kick out that
damn night
i don't want to see that knight on g6
yeah but you want to see this knight on
d5 yeah this one i like
i like your knife
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to go here and then i'm going to try to
get the side around oh that's so
dangerous
dangerous looking mv
he's trying to do the same let's go up
four
f4 beautiful and now we open the bishop
now the knight comes to deep or i gotta
think yeah yeah that's kind of uh oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's okay i'm
gonna have to go
now the other group comes to f1 i don't
really know what this is leading to yet
but something something promising
okay he takes it that surprises me a bit
what does he want
is a very cool person kind of like me oh
you're getting a chance well
in the opinion of my chat i think i'm
making a good math
right right chat
don't let me down now oh we got the ring
we got a raid
thank you so much
i'll try to go live then
you should yeah i'll try to go live
how was your stream aquatic
wrong
what's wrong
you were wrong listen peter's just being
peter ignore him
wrong
okay how dare you
cmvl thought i was you have to deal so
you thought i could you could play
rookie one shot oh there's a knight
protecting that squirm
when was i born
nine to nine to six ninety-five
you're so
old
who said that was a rain oh there was a
rain
from you yeah that was a rain
okay now i have to focus
is
and then nice
yeah
i did see that ah
you didn't see my idea oh wait it does
work no it doesn't wait it does it
doesn't
he's got rookie five
oh [ __ ] he's got this
oh no oh wait
do i losers is a draw
yes you got kf1 ah yeah
no
it loses ah
[ __ ]
unbelievable
just unbelievable
it's okay
we're under control
things are under control
[Music]
things are all under completely winning
out of the opening i mean it wasn't even
close
it wasn't even close
what is h4
h4 is to push the um
it's to push
e5 and you're playing what's his name
it's okay we don't tilt we don't do
we're chilling
we're having fun
when you're playing and wait while you
are playing and watching the game are
you kidding me you're you're watching
the game while being while playing no i
mean i can't believe i messed that up it
was just absolutely unbelievable it's
okay you're gonna take him over the next
game
wow
what a discipline that's very impressive
uh
that's rain
nice
it's okay daniel we don't tilt
we don't tilt
we keep up
we're here for the the atmosphere
we're here for chat
right
yes no yes
yes and for winning
pepper one
thousand beats dina looks great when the
sub alert replaces her face
getting soft all of a sudden you will
get him next time what do you mean by
that
would have been being so being soft it's
not being soft
that's being very um
very not soft
that's
plastic pepper
um
the self did
pray cuttery vibes
oh aqua
aqua how are you doing aqua we miss you
there is a lot of things going on here
we need you
let's go back we need you we need to
like water needs um
like aqua needs bottle like aqua
you're welcome
jack 3m thank you so much for
subscribing
oh dj you're being
he just bang bang bang bang everybody
i'll support you
and support you
knight on
b5
[Music]
yeah a little bit um
a little bit annoying
don't be stupid
don't be stupid
be very
stupid just be stupid
um i like your knife only five yeah but
i'm down upon i have to create counter
play
[Music]
yeah probably not like that
it's just a ball who cares about pawns
one phone is um
it's not um not the end of the world
it is here is it is work c7
wants to take you
you don't let him
play smart
you should f6 protecting e7
what if bishop takes six oh it was your
move right that makes no sense
[Music]
[Music]
i like your group
it's not helping i guess
oh it works now wow
[Music]
right
he's checking you
it's fine
i'm down too many points
[Music]
okay
you have
30 seconds
doesn't matter
you know um played once for my sub
battle and he was very
he was he lost
that's understandable understandable
is good
yeah but mbl is is better no
foreign
the world thought you were at the spa
with a glass of champagne in four
seasons
yeah i also
this is where i was
this is where i was pepper but then um
then daniel said um
then he said that he needed to
to take care of um of mvl and they said
yeah sure why not let's take care of
did emilion ask
in interview you playing bullet 1a was
the way of gaining confidence for his
match
that's actually a good idea i should ask
it i should ask it
i should definitely ask it
something you miss watching chat streams
daily
beautiful
then you don't look at the chat
it's very much i forgot play hd
you see it's chad's fault is she was it
like in theory
the theory of
i like your um i like your bishop on
this on c1
let me bring it yeah i need to get it
out
mixtapes
magnus is online mine this is online
what what website how do you know long
this is online i mean i i would
challenge him if he's online even on
leaches
i don't think he's actually online i
think he just tweeted
twist
he is online on the chess
i should challenge him okay let's go
i mean who is mvl if you if you want to
challenge manus
i will challenge him
wow but then i'll just go back to
playing
i'll resign if he accepts but then i'll
have to focus then i'll have to focus
completely okay okay okay
we'll focus completely because i'm
playing badly today unfortunately what
can you get for um
how they say
how big can be your strike for no no no
if the agreement is if if magnus is
online i can plan it only
yeah it doesn't matter that's actually
my my agreement it doesn't work for for
peru no
it's just magnus
i'll hear a sound
what's this oh yeah it'll hit a little
sound on my headphones
okay okay okay
terribly
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i like your pawn on e5
you do
that's a very beautiful pawn thank you
what if i
what if you
an interesting idea but
just not focusing well after all this
commentary
commentary is hard i don't think people
realize that
i think they do um
rebecca harris miles is rebecca harris
right i'm a very nervous oh you're back
i'm rebecca harris
yeah i didn't know it's you
you're rebecca harris okay
you're back at harris i thought he might
have tricked mvl a little bit
yay let's go
no but he's
starting screaming
come on i feel like i'm better every
game than i screwed up something
okay we've gone straight in this moment
you know not to screw
how can i do it again
and i have this
oh
if you go uh
rook c4 all right
i want to go
[Music]
why did i do that okay
that's great
amazing that was the night i actually
tricked him then he tricked me then i
tricked him again you see you can be
back your eyes are stream working yeah
but i'm not sure i'm gonna have the the
goods um i'm not
i'll see because of the mic they might
say that this
come on magnus do you think magnus is
scared of me rebecca yeah
he doesn't like women
i mean doesn't like women
how did you find this username uh it's
just the tv show character
[Music]
don't
what's the tv show name limitless
limitless limit limitless limitless
mistake this guy initially
what is it about
it's about uh it's a long story it's
nothing special i i didn't think my
electric account would become such a
meme
come on magnus
you know you want to play me right i
think minos respects the fact that you
want to you would mature at the moment
playing against uh what is his name
maxine
and he wants you to concentrate on on
that because this is way more important
tonight and
i'm in trouble
what the hell what is this guy smelling
he's smoking um
shisha whoa max thank you
max appreciate it oh you're supposed to
thank you sorry
yes
you call supreme you're playing on vl
you're playing world champion you should
be concentrated
if miles doesn't hate hoon he would play
diana
yeah
that's what i just say
this is exactly what he was saying
another magnum suite
what is that wouldn't it be cool if
magnus accepted
that was a wonderful game
wait but you were the best player on
league chats i'm the highest rated i
wouldn't say i'm the best how can how
did you become the hot okay
i'm just gonna bullet okay okay okay you
i should stop asking you questions no
it's okay
how many stops for shoulder massage
i think it's gonna be um
what did you say five hundred thousand
five hundred yeah to a thousand
hundred
thousand
i think five hundred is fine five
hundred five how much money is it it's
over a thousand bucks
no but he can do that but
wow i don't think yeah i see more
yeah it has to be at least like
ten thousand dollars yeah at least ten
thousand dollars
yeah
[Music]
wait what if i should sweet what is this
magnus is scared of me yeah
dropping so much rating
it's okay
i'm having a good time i'm having a
great time
enjoying still enjoying my chat
yeah
yeah i think it's my computer
[Music]
let's go faster
let's go the bishop on e3 looking great
and looking at the amazing scene that i
have no time c5 phones
you have no time
time is a washing machine
what does that mean
it's a good song wow did he just give
a rook
congratulations all right let's play the
variation that peter taught me
what is that
this variation
and the word didn't work
well
it's
painting
daddy really riley
is this strange yep well maybe i'm
playing the french what else is more fun
oh yeah yeah true
your stream is not working no but don't
worry about it it's just my computer
inside and your new computer guys when
someone can donate me two thousand bucks
please do
please do a little fundraiser for gina
yeah fundraiser for two thousand bucks
and i'll buy some so magnus is posting
tweets
yeah
but i don't know what he's tweeting
about
should we look or is it
okay let's let's go to twitter
see what magnus is feeling about
maybe they are there they can't be
trolling because you know when you're
commentating the games
it's your time i don't think it's your
time that's great real pun panda thank
you so much for the sub
uh he said he won't bring him
um don't look at the chat okay you're
concentrating
you need to beat him
number three
he probably knows that you're streaming
yeah and he probably knows that i'm here
so he's tuned into the stream that he
does yeah well he
so yeah maybe he will pop in after the
match why is your internet so sorry so
he's probably um
but he will he will have extra pressure
and uh you need to use this pressure
against him yeah ideally yeah
ideally no here you will you will you
will gain eight h6 you can remind him
about his game
versus uh what was this game the last
game of the candidates that
did you lose it
or the king on age not eight of uh on f8
with the with the last game of the
candidates before the pandemic of
on girl be it please it would be eight
i actually want him to play with b8
because g5 stuff is nice there's ump
song but you're not gonna do it
it's too much for passer i'm gonna see
what he's up to for now
okay
are you madness
um
do you think magnus feels brave it's not
that impressive of course he will yeah
he's played me before many many times
yeah he he like he first of all he
didn't even mean what he meant
what he said he didn't even mean it and
secondly he's just gonna he's gonna
change his mind anyway
he came up with an interesting idea
one of those is coming to madrid
i should be able to win this
taking the knights i have to
and then pushing the ball
bishop d1
no we gotta go here you know because we
gotta go we gotta create a passer sure
oh this is dangerous for him this is
true
and then g5
i think he said he is
now that lareza has gone back to his
bullet roots i'm sure he'll be inspired
in the win tomorrow
is trying to motivate him i guess yeah
and then another tweet can't let you do
that buddy i'm the ambassador for
responsible gambling betting my car that
you will so do you know what are you
doing play against nipple and you shoot
is he playing against nepo of course
of course of course he's playing
otherwise otherwise nepal will play
against hikaru i mean for us it's better
than nepal plays against probably
that's gonna
explode the chess world
yeah people are going to be
batting my card oh my god did i just
wonder
no freaking wait no no no no no
this is said come on
bingo i think i know how to win this
wait what are you doing
where faster they are
you know
you know who you're dealing with the
author of why are you waiting for bishop
a4 where you can do it already what is
bishop's on d7 yeah but you can do it
bishop a4 i mean why can't why don't you
move
i think you could have
it
yay
we're beating mvl
four three amazing even mines cannot do
that that's right
that's right damn girl
daniel dropping russian pickup lines
that's it instagram
mastering complex end games practical
lessons on critical ideas and plans
it's exactly how i would say
miles is trying to get more money for
the next
world championship yay that's correct
that's exactly it
i've got a nice position i have to win
this one you think it's nice yeah if i
win this one i'm really going to tilt
him
you want to tilt poor maxine i do you're
so mean
let's go it's okay
no people come on magnus you know you
want to play rebecca but he's online
right yeah yeah maybe he's playing
through
i would see it you would see it it would
say it shows yeah
what don't
what don't
don't what
peter how are you doing how's your day
aren't you supposed to be working or
peter never works no worries somehow he
never has any work
because you work for him
yeah well some of us do the work
so like
you do the work
and uh
and he just takes the percentage
basically right yep so that's why you
you immediately understand how it is
okay
the greek laugh him
agnes come on wake up i see i see
wake up wake up
no but miles can't accept your your
invitation when
you know
you're playing vl
no but he doesn't know that
you don't think madhu shows your
no i think he must have watched your
streams
i mean he watches cicara streams so he
watches rebecca streams so he watches
rebecca streams exactly rebecca harris
i thought it was artemia at some point
really yeah
what are we doing here
okay now is putting me through the meat
grinder mid grinder
57 what was the problem 66 is very
unpleasant
no it doesn't work pg7 doesn't work
because of real cap six king f6195
oh
kingy six rook e1 exactly oh yeah
good calculation yum now i'm busted and
there goes my win streak
unless i can save this position which is
possible once
uh
[Music]
okay okay
e5 okay
you gotta go here
knight dixie seven ah ah
oh it's okay i don't think it's the end
of the world okay whoa
that that one i did not see
species okay it's not the end of the
world
oh he's got this
oh my god that was really good
okay
it's really not the end of the world
yeah you gotta go d5 or d4 i gotta be
fast and i can yeah because
it's faster than you usually are
it's an easy thing to do
you just push them all
through some baby
um i mean he's a pull up
where's his ear coming from
oh you wanna
after that i can make it actually no
that's okay it's okay we concentrate we
concentrate on on the on the rook
considering the most important rook
scene
oh look
okay it's ring is gonna play diamond
can you see eight
is attached to d5
roof
[Music]
and then
wow beautiful
this is jack do you want to check
could you shark is not that
it's coming
he's putting pressure on you
oh he's repeating he wants to draw you
don't want to draw
wow
[Music]
tricks
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh my god and yes rebecca harris still
hasn't accepted your invitation no
doctor nectar scene
who's that that's magnus
oh yeah okay open my chat
that's exactly what i meant all right
open my channel yeah so that you can see
the reaction yeah yeah yeah because
that's the best part you know yes i'm
there i'm there i'm there oh my god i
don't have no idea how i managed that's
so beautiful
wow
damn
girl okay
i'm gonna
yeah yeah make it switch the conditioner
[Music]
it's a yeah i'm just gonna
stop it
damn girl feels gotta be tilted
let's do two more let's win another one
well i didn't really win that one but
that felt like a win
yeah oh yeah after that
zero one second
wow
usually c5 in such positions is good but
yeah
okay
okay nice i like the bishop on b2
threatening to g7
thank you
uh wasn't dean always rooting for mvl
yeah i was but i mean i cannot respond
well in the situation like this but i am
i mean secretly of course i want to be
in front of yo
yeah we all still did he's playing badly
but i gotta capitalize on this game wait
a minute she switched teams
just for just for one night
just for tonight
let's flip flopping
the best of them
what does flip-flopping mean
[Music]
yeah all right so here
that's funny okay concentrate guys don't
distract focus don't distract
there is uh
there is you have a great center you
really do
have a very interesting idea yeah what
is it
wait you're probably not gonna like it
bishops oh you're gonna give him a pawn
yes yes yes but he's gonna play a4 and
destroy me oh you take him on e6 and
then you queen g7 mates
ideas like that yeah oh that's it's very
um it's really dangerous
you're so dangerous
i forgot about a4 we forgot about the
forum okay now we're going to get a
crazy do not forget about the form uh-oh
now what this is very bad is it because
uh he's coming after me
something interesting
okay i have to play like this
takes it
i watch ricardo stream file tuesday
during the candidates the rest day and
win the next game
you want the next game or
or commentators what is new moss did
they even do a
internship what's new mods
did you mean did you mean me
it's soon to be 2 am by the way yeah
but we are we're very high
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
okay that a3 phone is very dangerous
knight coming to f5
then uh
doing something like
annoying
i'm the new mom why did i go with
i that grand back who's glenn back
will this stream be saved i can watch
now why can't you watch
oh yeah sure it will be streamed saved
it will be saved the rook is attacked
we're going to
d2
and then um
the knight is attacked
oh wow your queen is under attack
that's so beautiful
oh wait 20 seconds only
check
check
huh
[Music]
five and a half to three and a half last
one maybe
maybe
poor mvl
he's suffering at the hands of rebecca
yay rebecca is showing him uh
becca
your short name is becca my hands are
shaking after that game ah you're pro
are you proud of yourself extremely you
should be proud that was a nice game i
mean i i did outplay him at some point
yeah
yeah you did you showed great fights
very great fighters i know i don't give
a [ __ ] before castling that's the rule
yeah because otherwise he can cuss alone
well otherwise he can take and play g4
beautiful
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna do
something weird your bishop is very ugly
you know that thank you for letting me
know i didn't realize that yeah now you
knew
then the knight to b6 and then um knight
to c4 so now do you guys see that it's
weird that the the other guy crushed me
mm-hmm if this is my score against
danielle
the url you're in a casco who can be
another guy who crashed you who didn't
crash i mean hicaro he car destroys me
regularly wait you think hikaru is
playing underground around no way at
this time i mean
at this tournament
in this city at this hour yeah exactly
kraken
no i don't know he doesn't play online
but you know what's what's weird about
the mystery yeah is that i wrote
jordakescu and he didn't deny it it
would be one thing if he said oh it's
not me
okay but he said it was him maybe he
that's that's the teamwork like us the
the big fools
why are you gonna sleep
how are you doing
charlotte chesson are still in the chat
room as well got absolutely everybody
yeah everybody is here what is mvp's
chess comes timon
go get go to bed y'all what's yo
what's ya uh why i'm gonna tell
big is asking why aren't we we're
sleeping
we're gonna go sleep yeah i'm gonna go
we're just we just we're farming mvl
we're finishing farming at the end we're
finishing farming beyond then we go to
let's just sleep good plan
yeah
did i come to
charlotte for a month and we'll teach
you all the english
lingo
i mean um having spent already two weeks
here with this um chess com people
i kind of improved already great but
there's plenty there's like
lingo that's specific to charlotte you
know okay okay i mean i'm if i have the
the invitation that i'm i'm doing it
have fun cuties big foods thank you
teach her
murican brother
who's brook morgan brother
who's that american brother yeah
i actually don't know american is
something it's some reference to
something okay
uh
i do speak french but right now we speak
english
microwave guy yeah that's broke that's
benjamin
that's benjamin
okay i'm in a tough position here hmm
there's a pollen seeds for you guys you
wanna take it you don't wanna take it
are you a man are you not a man i'm
definitely the most definitely a man
you're most happily but not likely
but not sure yet not totally in heaven
yeah
right okay so you took the ball that's
good
um
yeah but he also took the pun oh
beautiful
beautiful no no it's very ugly it's very
ugly sorry i didn't mean that i like his
bishops
they're they're super powerful they're
like see we'll see we'll see about that
okay we're doing a whole lot of praising
of mbl's position
okay i'm back to defending okay you're
right
you're not mvl's rights
uh
where are you gonna put your knights is
that vl chill or is he gonna be okay if
i decline his next challenge
no i know he is chill
well i mean danya that's the question if
if like you decline me what what's the
reason why you decline it it's late it's
late but you're not gonna go to bed are
you
probably not i mean what time did you go
to bed i mean yeah because
yeah yesterday so so you see what i mean
so if you if you decline now so then
then after i get the notification on my
phone that you're playing again online
maybe yeah you see the scenario it's not
it's not how it works so like
look at that move it's a beautiful move
these really well
on the rook oh
it's like says the guy known for his
dick generate powers i'm offering a draw
you're offering your draw don't overdraw
flag him no not mvl okay we respect them
real not in vl okay
can't do it oh he's not offering rematch
that means that he's watching the stream
he's watching the stream he's watching
the stream
he wants he wants you to be the first to
invite him out yeah to invite him out
exactly to ask him out to ask him out
he wants you to ask him out first he has
his digging team
[Music]